welcome to film courage this is episode
I'm Karen worden I almost jumped in
before you there and I'm David Branum
today's guest is actor Kevin Chapman
Kevin was a regular on the Showtime
series Brotherhood he's also had
recurring roles on lost rescue me and 20
for his film credits include ladder 49
Sunshine Cleaning Black Dynamite Mystic
River 21 grams Boondock Saints and more
Kevin currently portrays detective
Lionel Fusco on the CBS hit show Person
of Interest person of interest is the
collaboration between Jonah Nolan JJ
Abrams Bryan Burk Greg Clayman and
Richard Lewis like how you got the Jonah
Nolan right there yeah he goes by
Jonathan per person of interest centers
on ex-cia hitman in a scientist who team
up to prevent crimes before they happen
detective Lionel Fusco is a bad cop who
gets a chance to make things right and
special thanks to Wendy Shepard of
Studio matrix comm for arranging this
interview make sure to follow her at
Wendy Shepard
please welcome to film courage via
telephone mr. Kevin Chapman welcome
Kevin hi thanks for being here
yeah thanks for being here you know and
take a time out of your busy schedule
for for more Kevin please check out his
Facebook he's on Facebook now he's on
IMDB you can just take a look at that
long list of credits and he's on Twitter
Pio I Fusco that's fu sco and his
website Kevin Chapman com
Kevin going back to your beginning of
acting you know your career looks like
your IMDB credits start around 1998 did
you decide that you know you want to be
an actor you thought it'd be an exciting
career or was it something that it was
just at the core of who you are it just
no matter what you did the desire for it
would not leave you alone well you know
I have to be honest for that you know
acting found me I didn't find it and you
know I grew up in public housing my mom
raised four of us by herself and you
know where I lived
a lot of guys who who were going to be
actors no you know he's socially
acceptable to hit a ball out of the park
or to score a touchdown but you know
down to the corner and tell your buddies
you want to be an actor or tap-dance or
you know something that was out of the
norm and it just wasn't socially
accepted so I guess you know my my my
interest in the odds were this was
suppressed I guess at a very early age
just you know to the fact that I wanted
to fit in you know you know you come
from a home where you don't have a dad
and and your mom is always working to
put food on the table so you just want
to fit in somewhere so the last thing
you wanted to be was you know different
from the rest of the group so is there
was something that you know as I became
an adult it it it kind of came into my
life and I worked in a logistical
capacity with a director Ameritech Demi
who has since passed on but Teddy was a
fabulous director he directed blow
who's the man he did monument AB which
was the film I worked at them on um just
a fabulous dieted life with Eddie Murphy
and Martin Lawrence and was also the
creator of yo MTV raps so I worked I was
working for the city of Boston I was
working for the mayor's office and they
were making this movie monument have
within the city of Boston and I worked
logistical a lift with the director Ted
and Denis Leary and Edison and Ted were
very close and the two of them looked at
me one day they said can you act I said
I said of intelligent enough to you know
so they gave me the script and that full
my name it happened I went home and read
it and Ted said oh when you look at the
role of Mickey Pat so I I read the film
read the script and and and had lunch
with them him and Dennis the next day
and I gave them my interpretation of the
character and and they both looked at me
and said well we think we'd like you to
put this guy so I was like okay and of
course you know I was full of fear
didn't
know what I was doing you know I didn't
know a close-up from you know a rigged
shot from a tee shot you know I just I
just had no idea what I was doing and
and so once I was exposed to that first
experience I kind of you know got bit
with the bug and I began to take classes
with you know various coaches in the
Boston area and I think I started
pursuing pursuing different projects and
I got casted him you know side of house
rules and in the bedroom
what's the world's can happen I got a
cast small roles and all these
productions that were taking place in
Boston where I lived and then I said to
myself if I'm really gonna you know
advance in this industry I'm gonna need
to develop a craft so I quit my job put
everything on the back of a u-haul truck
and I drove to California and I just
worked at the House of Blues at night as
a doorman and I studied acting during
the day and that mean I went through
that process for about two years until
uh nice food casting a Mystic River
Sukhumi pretty much how it all began
going back yeah that's an amazing story
and I just love that and I'm wondering
going back to where you were raised
because I also grew up in public housing
I know there's a lot of drama never a
dull moment so did you take some of that
even though you hadn't been sort of you
hadn't taken acting in college did you
take some of those experiences and
channel them into characters some of
that high energy frustration that I'm I
think you know I mean acting is about
betraying life in in the way I looked at
it was I had a toolbox that was pretty
full because I have led a pretty full
life I've come in contact with people
from Yale to jail I like my so I I you
know I have these experiences with these
various people that that I'm able to
draw from to to develop these characters
you know
and and you know in which liking the
project myself the thing I always look
for is truth in the character you know I
try not to play things that are too
far-fetched you know unless we do
something like you know like we're just
having fun like something like Black
Dynamite were it's just a bunch of guys
and a camera you know and a good script
and and and having fun you know but you
know anytime like even you know even
with Lionel Fusco on person of interest
you know when I when I read the script I
look at it and I say to myself is there
a Lionel Fusco out there somewhere in
the world hmm
I believe that there is mm-hmm you know
and and and I think that's what helps me
make these selections with these
characters you know you know so I mean
that's I guess that's you know that's
been pretty much my my view on on how
you're able to take something from a
page and craft it into something that's
believable you have to find the truth in
it to make it believable and I guess
that's my process anyway okay you know I
mean going back to the decision because
here you are I mean you're thrust into
this role you know you're working you
know with Denis Leary and and and and
Demi you know and that's a great
opportunity in front of you but then but
then still you make the decision of like
you know what I want to I want to get
into this craft this is something I want
to explore I want to see if I can do
this for a living and so right right at
the beginning you know you're in Boston
and New York is only a couple hours away
and yet you decide you know what I'm
gonna I'm gonna just go all out to LA to
tell us about that decision about
bypassing New York and going all the way
to LA well this I mean I you know there
was I believe this farm one more
opportunity in Los Angeles where is in
New York you know there there is there
is you know if you want to do theater
but if you want to do film and
television hype and that's my opinion
you know that's the that's the that's
the beauty of this industry that we work
and it's all subjective you know it's
it's what I think and what works for me
it may not work for you it may not work
for the next person
but it's what works for me and I felt
that if I was going to work in film and
television I had to be in Los Angeles
because I felt that that is the hub of
the industry I'm even you know person of
interest I'm playing you know a New York
detective I was casted out of Los
Angeles
you know so that's that was really the
thing with me I knew that I had to go
where there was more opportunity so
that's you know that was pretty much it
was a pretty it was a pretty cut-and-dry
decision today you know I mean you had
you had the screen credit at that time
and you had the connections the
relationships from working on that
project and yet still coming to LA I
mean you're in a new land and you're
starting from scratch I mean how were
you gonna stand out amongst all the
other actors here I mean what was the
like the plan and the strategy cuz you
said you you worked that night and part
of the plan was the study during the day
study acting we know what else did you
do what else is part of your strategy
and sort of like you know to start
working your way in there was no plan B
you know there was no plan B it was you
know I'm I'm a guy who you know I put it
on ten and pull the knob off and that's
the way I've always lived my life
whatever whatever I'm doing yeah I went
to LA and I said I'm gonna be an actor
but there was never well if acting
doesn't work out maybe I'll do this I
mean it was this there was no plan B and
it never never has been a fun day you
know I I feel that you have to follow
your heart you know and it's like you
know it's it's like it's like if you go
to a circus for instance not to get to
you know
that's all Asafa 'but to you know kind
of cliche if you if you've ever gone to
a circus and you see the guy in the
trapeze when the guy in the trapeze
leaves that trapeze he believes that the
other individual and the other end is
gonna catch him he puts all his trust in
the fact that that individual on the
other trapeze is going to catch him
as he free falls in the air and that's
that's kind of my philosophy on life you
know I kind of believe that if I if I
believe something's gonna happen then I
just I just go forward and I'm not
saying it always works out but I just I
don't I don't think of what if he
doesn't catch me mm-hmm
you know so I guess that's kind of my
view on it right and even in having that
belief about yourself and having you
know said earlier that you've lived a
very full life do you ever doubt
yourself as an actor how confident are
you in what you bring to the table is
there ever a noise that says mmm I felt
pretty confident I've looked at some
amazing directors I mean I've worked you
know I mean like my first big movie I'm
being directed by Clint Eastwood am
sitting across the table from Sean Penn
you know talk about getting thrown off
too deep into the pool you know and you
know it was bizarre it was funny because
when we were doing mr. Gribble you know
you know Clint said to me you know how
do you feel kid nice I looked I said
come on it's a home game and and you
know I mean that was it that was a great
experience with that so that the bar
being set so high you know working on
that film I mean you know it was great
because we went out I mean Sean was very
gracious you know with me
you know Laurence Fishburne was gracious
with me Kevin Bacon I'm still friends
with to this day you know Tim Robbins
you know I've just had an amazing
amazing experience on that film and you
know I was you know between you know
Sean Tim Kevin fish Marcia Gay Harden
Laura Lenny I'm with about almost 200
years with the vacuum experience you
know that's that's moving Clint out of
the equation you know there's another 50
years there and you know and it was
great because every night after work we
all spent our time together we did table
reads on our own on Fridays Sean would
arrange a room at the hotel we were
staying at and we would have food to
live it and we would
we would reread the script every Friday
to find more beats for next week's work
you know you know because there's you
know you know Clinton is is is legendary
for not you know not giving a lot of
takes you know you know he's a guy he
watching he just films a lot of his
films the story is told in the master
and I've had conversations with him
about that you know I I asked him
specifically you know why he did so few
takes and he said I've never seen
anything and take eight that he didn't
see him take two you know and he says
you know I hire people who can do the
job you know and then you know I asked
about you know his stories being told me
master and he said that's the way life
is filled you know he said you don't you
know if you like life and close-ups is
if you didn't it's it's viewed in the
wide you know
so you know you know your selfie both
filmmakers you know that when you tell a
story in the master or in a wide shot
you know you move along at a pretty
rapid pace it's when you start getting
into the close-ups and start you know
where things have a tendency to kind of
bog down you know but uh he would do as
a master he'd do the reverse and you
know we'd be moving on and you know it
was just remarkable experiences in this
experience I look back on my life you
know just it was just amazing but you
know I worked with him I looked at Tony
Scott I looked at Philip noise DJ Caruso
I mean I've worked with some some really
great Jay Russell's really great
filmmakers mm-hmm and and that's what I
get excited about I get excited about
working with filmmakers you know we
directors are the ones that excited me
because they bring their their their
different styles and the different
philosophies on on the artifact and and
I listen that you know and you know this
business it's the advice is you know you
take what you need you leave the rest
you know and that's that's pretty much
how you know I like to operate
constantly I'm constantly mining
constantly even on television you know
where it's very scripted you know and
you have all these approvals you have to
get the studio approval and that
approval and you know because everybody
wants you know to to know that the story
and everything is going in the right way
and it's hard to improv or go outside
the lines on television but you know
even I may do a take where I take it in
a totally different direction but and
then when they come back for the next
take I'll bring it back to the script
and what that will do is it'll give me
subtext and what I'm saying that's
scripted you know it will create a
little create different subtext and in
the in the line which rules will help me
move it in a different direction without
without diverting from what the script
so it's just were all these different
things from all these different
different actors and different
experiences and you know I've been very
blessed I've been very blessed of you
know I you know I feel might might my my
next great role or my you know my next
great performance hasn't come yet you
know and I think when I feel like I've I
got a handle on it that's probably when
I'll do something else you know that's
the thing that excites me about this
business you only as good as the last
film on the last television show now you
did you know you know you have to just
keep mining and keep digging and keep
fighting and keep stretching and growing
and that's what I try to do I try you
know I'll study I'll study with anybody
who tells me that they have something
that is going to be useful to me and I
could put in my toolbox to help make a
better performance or a better actor or
you know a better scene whatever it is
I'm trying to accomplish you know I mean
speaking of speaking of your experience
with with with the directors you've
worked with Kevin we have this great
that we have this question if for Marty
laying he wants to know do you have any
advice for new directors and how they
should work with actors and any tips or
things that they don't that you can
suggest I mean just have a vision you
know have a vision what walk on the set
as a
are prepared in in in in in in just you
know that's the best the best thing you
can do I mean you know coinies would for
instance I felt had a remarkable way of
working if the call time was seven
o'clock you were blocking at 7:05 you
know you didn't come in and have you
breakfast and you know get dressed and
there wasn't there was none of that you
know what I mean
when you show up on the set of seven
o'clock your car pulled up there was a
PA waiting for you they opened you
toilet sigmata mr. Chapman we'd like to
bring you right down to the set please
get on with a set Clint would block the
scene okay you're gonna come through the
door you're gonna come over here you're
gonna pick up the drink you're gonna do
this you can do that okay guys while the
crews light that you're getting ready
mm-hmm when the crews done lightening
your shooting
there's no is no hanging around there's
no you know you mean he you know and
when we could mr. Griffith Clint was
Jesus I don't know he was 70 what's the
82 now he's probably 75 years old I mean
he just it was like it was remarkable to
see the energy that this guy had I mean
I should be some less than 75 years old
to have the energy you know it's just
you know it was just unbelievable to see
it moves here like 82 now he's still
making movies you know and you walk in
there any sets a professional it's you
know sufficient it's it's you know it's
it's just amazing you know your water
directors and that Tony Scott was
another one's like it's got his team
around them you know you know you go in
there bang you block it you know you do
you think and then you know you go home
and that's the way it should be you know
there's nothing worse when you work with
a director who's an and he's you know he
or she is wishy-washy and well I don't
know what do you think about this and
maybe we can do it here and you know
that's just that just kind of takes the
window at least out of my sails you know
hmm
you know you get up in the morning you
you can you know you got today's work
ahead of you you just you want to get in
there and you just want to tackle it you
know and so that's I think that's the
biggest attribute I think there's a good
director is just having a cohesive plan
and knowing what you want to accomplish
for the day and knowing what you're
looking for from your actor now you know
because you're a writer you're a
director it doesn't make everything that
you direct alright the best it's I mean
you know there's got to be a
collaborative process there but you
can't let the collaborative process blob
down the entire process which I've seen
happen you know I've worked with some
with some big stars that were the
director I almost felt was like a scared
to director you know because he was
intimidated by their notoriety or their
celebrity and what happens there is that
the process becomes bogged down a little
bit you know because now that you know
the actor has a you know position how he
feels it should be of course the writer
has his vision that you know then the
next thing you know the D piece chiming
in and it's like you you know you get
people to stare out look at each other
trying to figure out the shot and when
that process happens for me and I can
only speak for myself it it kind of
takes the wind out of your sails so that
director needs to own that leadership
they can't yeah you need to own it you
need to own it but also you need to you
need to be prepared you need to you know
you need that you need to have a vision
you need to have a plan I think when you
don't have that plan that
he was actually where I'm sitting in my
car and it wasn't backing up next to me
and I apologize okay well the sound is
great so going back to what you said
Kevin about you came to LA you were a
bouncer for a while at the House of
Blues we know so many talented people
that they're still doing those jobs and
they are amazing what is it that
separates those who work in the industry
and make their living from it and those
who never become a working actor they
might have a few parts here and there
but you know it was funny I mean I
worked in a bar for a bank and Echo Park
all shortstop pretty little bar I worked
at that bar when I got Mystic River hmm
I finished Mystic River I went back to
my job at the bar Wow baby was like you
crazy you just did a movie with you know
and I'm like yeah that's fine and then
you know you have to be a part of life
how can you betray life if you're not a
part of it
Dell when I'm not working I have a
friend who has a has an extra casting
company for commercials and I'm not
working uncle doing extra work on
commercial no people look at me and they
go hey I know yeah I'm the guy with
craft service at it's like you know it's
about experience that's what that's what
this business is about for me I should
say that's what it's about for me is
about the experience is about the
experience of being on this set and
meeting different people and talking
different ideas and exchanging different
stories and exchanging you know
information and you know because all
that stuff goes right in my toolbox
you know and that's and that's when you
know I can walk in or somebody says to
me hey you know can you play you know
yeah sorry about that
come on the cell phones we could put a
person on the moon but we can't finish
the cell phone conversation anywhere in
the world so you know that's that's
really what it's about for me you know
so keeping being in the midst of life
and not sort of being you know that just
so removed from
people that you kind of lose touch with
reality everything yeah I just don't I
don't I've never I've never played that
you know I've never played that well hey
I'm here and you are here type thing you
know with some people playing this
business you know it's like you know I
mean hey let's face it we all have some
level of an ego we wouldn't be in the
business sir
you know so we have some level of ego
but some people just you know have a
tendency to take it you know people are
more concerned about you know who their
publicist is and who you know getting
ripped at CAA than they worried about
going to walk you know like you know
that's that's what I see anyway you know
this is you know and and as I say when I
don't want to finish mr. Gribble back I
was I was tending bar here Here I am I
just did this movie that you know we
knew was going to make a lot of noise
you know Dennis Lehane book directed by
Clint Eastwood you know starring you
know a bunch of movie stars you know and
we knew that we wouldn't be made the
film that it was something it was gonna
be something special but you know very
interesting thanks listen to these
people talk about you know I'm going to
William Mars next week and going you
know in its place because you're
good-looking and you got six-pack abs
and you wear the right hair gel you
think you should be away Mars how about
working on the craft of acting you know
how about working at being a better
actor as opposed to you know being seen
on the red carpet and you know we all
know that's part of the business but as
I say I find in some experiences you
have people that are so wrapped up into
that thing that you lose focus of what
really is important and that's doing
good work that's to this actor anyway
you know very true I mean yeah we're all
needy in some sense or we wouldn't go
into this business because there is a
level of validation that we get I'm
wondering what are you doing to drum up
work though I mean are you relying
strictly on an agent or a manager or are
you doing your own legwork in between
jobs I mean it's funny you don't watch
it like Black Dynamite I got I mean
that's the beauty of this business you
never know who's watching you you never
know who was a fan who's not a fan you
know
it's all subjective I've walked into
auditions where people like oh I love
you and this that another thing and then
I walk into other auditions and they go
who you and what have you done again hmm
you know I've got Black Dynamite for
instance at the gym Michael Jai White
came up to me and he goes hey I broke
this you know this great screenplay it's
very funny I've been a fan of yours
since Mystic River I'd love for you to
be in it you know I'm like sure here's
my address
drop the script by the house I get out
of the gym I come home I put some house
in LA there's this big huge silver
Hummer sitting in my driveway I'm like
who's this I walk in Michael Jai White
sitting in my living you know he's like
I got the script and I read the script I
was like 15 pages and I was this thing's
hysterical I meant you know I called my
age and I said look I don't know what
they got some money I don't know you
know I said just make the deal just make
the deal I said I know that they're you
know trying to piece this thing together
I said funny I want to do it make the
deal so I did it for you know for
virtually no money because I was a I was
I thought the materials fantastic B I
was flattered the fact that that he
approached me just straight up and
that's you know you don't have all the
lawyers and the agents and the managers
and that whole thing it was like it was
just two guys talking to guys who love
what they do for a living trying to make
something that they thought was a good
piece of material and um and it was
great you know I thought you know
unfortunately I don't think that the
studio that bought it you know I I think
honestly think they were a little scared
of it I thought that they they thought
that you know I thought I think maybe
the studio I know loves us just pure
speculation so maybe I shouldn't comment
on that but I feel that that movie
should have had a bigger life than what
it did and we'll just leave it at that
a lot of people love that movie has call
status I believe you know that comes up
quality yeah yeah yeah people love the
film it's funny cuz I when I go you know
I've been it you know I was in boondocks
change which is like another cult film
as well
you know yeah so it's funny when I go
like the supermodel my wife is something
obviously checking out some kid will be
like oh my you know you know Kevin we
have a lot of actors who believe that it
is the agent or or manager who knows how
to sell the actor and get the actor the
work you know and in your career I mean
you just you just told us a story how
you know you get a role just from going
to the gym so so how true is that in
your experience in terms of you're
getting all your work through because
your agent or manager knows how to sell
you you know what indications in the
managers I mean I have I've had one
agent in one manager since I've been in
the business Mike my managers Ellen
Meyer and my agent sue wall and you know
Sue Ellen Harry goal it was they were
you know they were gold Marshak nautical
talentworks
you know
I laughed because you know not to not to
be you know the actor comes on here and
drops a lot of names but you know Sean
Penn I got a lot of a great advice in
shop and when I we did mr. Gura as I
said we we became you know we became
movie buddies is what I like to call it
you know mm-hm
I we did Mystic River together and then
he called me and asked me to come to a
scene with him at 21 grams right after
we did Mystic River which I went down to
Memphis and did and you know Sean has
been in this business for you know 30
plus years his dad was in the business
and is a very probably one of the most
intelligent human beings I've ever met
my entire life for men who has no formal
education you know as a man who's never
gone to college in his life and you know
he can sit down with heads of state and
not only sustain the conversation he'll
he'll carry the conversation you know
and you know he he always said to me you
know he said changing agents is like
changing seats in the Titanic you know
he says when you know when when when
you're when you're on the downslide your
business you know you know your career
it's just you're just
I'm flattered your career you know like
you know I my agent my manager worked
very hard for me but they also work
pretty hard for a lot of other people as
well you know I'm a firm believer that
work brings work in and I feel that I
continue to grow in this industry
because I continue to work on my craft
and and that's that's really it you know
I tried different things I'll be short
you know people come to me and they say
hey we've doing this short with you if
it's good material I don't care what it
is I don't care who's making it I don't
care who's distributing it I don't care
what star is in it you know good
material is good material and if it's
somebody with a camcorder in their back
yard and they put a good script in front
of me will then set up the camera let's
have at it
you know because you know that person
who's working with that camcorder in his
yard is not always going to be in a job
with a camcorder you know one day that
person is gonna be on a set and one day
that person is going to be helming a
movie somewhere he's gonna say I
remember you you the guy that I came to
me in my yard while I had my camcorder
you know and and that's that's the other
thing I look at as well you know I heard
a great story Laurence Fishburne told me
a fabulous story sittings work out a
movie one day and he said um this PA
come to him and he said hey I got the
script I'd love love for you to read it
and Morris Brown said yeah he goes I'd
love to hear but he goes I'm gonna go
get a cup of coffee you want one and the
PA said you're gonna get me a cup of
coffee
you said yeah I'm going to get one you
all when he said Oh cup of coffee we'll
come back we'll sit on the sidewalk and
we'll talk about your movie so he says
yeah so fist goes up and gets two cups
of coffee comes back since in the
sidewalk and listens to this kid's movie
well the PA was John Singleton the movie
was played in the hood and there was a
lot of people that they wanted before
Laurence Fishburne to play that role and
I won't get into the names you know the
obvious choices and monster and John
Singleton said I won't make that movie
without Laurence Fishburne
all because he was kind as
pa and got him a cup of coffee and he
took five minutes to sit down listen to
this guy's dream and that's something
that's all we still have stuck with me
and it resonated with me you know you
know my standing rides in with me in the
morning you know hmm
and we talked about today and we'll run
lines and you know cuz I know maybe one
day he's not always gonna be a standard
you know this is a business or another
you know for me it's about elevating
people you know it's not about telling
you how much better I am than you it's
about how can I help you chase your
dreams you know um I think that's
important that's important for me when I
speak I always be you know with my views
you know doesn't necessarily mean
they're right or wrong they're just what
works for me anyway yeah so this is
fitori I'm taken to it this is rich
conversation here we are we are on the
line with person of interest actor Kevin
Chapman he plays detective Lionel Fusco
on the CBS hit show and you can connect
with them on Twitter at Pio i Fusco
now is it correct Kevin that you have no
idea what will happen to your character
on person of interest from week to week
and you say you like this you like this
I'm sorry I do I race that I'd like to
take the journey with the character it
was like that my I was on another series
prior to this called Brotherhood which
was very critically acclaimed we won a
Peabody Award it was probably as I like
to call it one of the best unwatched
series ever made but uh you know that
was kind of the same way on that show as
well you know you never know it's a week
a week and I think I think a lot of
shows like uh I kind of taken that
approach I know the guys you know we had
some of the guys who worked on Sopranos
on our show a couple weeks ago they were
saying the same thing on Sopranos you
know he'd sit around you never know
who's who was going to buy the farm on
that episode you know Israel and I I
embraced that I embraced that process
because as I said you know it keeps you
loved it keeps you on the journey with
your character
and what's the standard day on the set
like what's the timeframe that you're
dealing with can you paint a picture
well I mean television you work you know
somewhere around a 13 hour day and you
know in films you can work you know as I
say you know you could work with a guy
like Clint Eastwood where you work an
eight-hour day I need to work with a
dial with like alejandro gonzalez who
you know who likes to shoot and shoot
and shoot and shoot and shoot you know
and they're both great filmmakers and
they're all right it's just different
styles you know but you know television
excuse it's you know the figures at 30
holiday birthday feast
very few television shows that shot less
right you know what goes into that day
exactly you know for the actors
listening that that just you know want a
better sense of the work that you're
putting in each day I mean you say you
drive to set with your stand-in you know
you're going back and forth with line
you know you're reading lines with him
and then once you ride this set what
happens from there well you you know
your body trailer you costume what we
hang it up the size will be there you
know don't market it or ask to get like
a cup of coffee and they use it bring a
cup of coffee to my trailer and I'll
just I'll stop my day I'll stop thinking
about the choices I'm gonna make you
know making sure I I for me the thing is
you know knowing the lines inside all
upside down because that gives you the
freedom to dance you know to kind of
dance within within the boundaries but
you can kind of dance to your own thing
you know for me it's only my process I
feel like it liberates me as an act of
humility have a none but complete
understanding of as a dialogue and you
know sometimes I'll talk to the writers
and ask them you know what they were
thinking when they wrote you know
specific phrase or a specific scene just
to really you know have a complete
understanding of them because like I
just feel that just be so much freedom
so I'll just kind of go for my day then
they'll take it out of here and make up
and they'll make it look pretty
then they'll bring you over to the you
know to the sound cart they'll fold eye
on you and goggle in you'll block the
scene and then they'll light it and then
you'll shoot it that's pretty much the
day I mean cuz it did it over and over
again they go right to the right to the
schedule for the day and and and folks
like I mean you know JJ Abrams and Jonah
Nolan are behind this one that the two
of the the creators and how often are
they on the set I mean are they are they
heavily involved with this with this
show or are they you know Jonah is Jonah
we have Jordan to killing all in Craig
plankton who is a showrunner mmm Greg
was also the showrunner on cold case is
not a bunch of great shows you wrote an
NYPD Blue
you know he's just a really great guy
and they have what they call the war
room in Los Angeles which is where all
the writers are you know some like other
shows like I say the show I worked on a
Showtime Brotherhood we had blink
masters and Henry Brown Mel and Blake
pastors was the creator Henry Brown
always a showrunner and they were on set
all the time and what they would do is
they would alternate um so you can
constantly have the writers here this is
a little bit different we have the
writing staff is in Los Angeles and what
they do is they deploy you know the
writer who is the head writer on that
specific episode out to New York and
they will stay from pre-production you
know they'll go over with the locations
and stuff with the directors and help
with the local casting and then they'll
stay for about the first five days of
the episode and then they'll go back to
Los Angeles and then they'll send out
another writer so whoever's doing the
the episode following the one that you
you're presently shooting so it's a
little bit different you don't get to
spend a lot of time with the writing
staff you know you kind of only see them
when they're popping in at either
episode you know I read somewhere
that you said about your character
detective Fusco that what's great about
Lionel is he's not really corrupt by
choice he just sort of fell in with the
wrong crowd and now he's at the how did
I end up here stage but in every episode
he's coming back to the light he's
definitely redeemable why why is he yeah
I mean it's really I think you know when
I play characters first of all anytime
with any character with a smile Fausto
any character I play but the first thing
I never do is judge the character okay
um you know why don't you be a good guy
doing bad things so he could be a bad
guy doing good things you know that's
that's up to the viewer you know know
what what the viewership think of Lionel
I look at that as it's none of my
business you know I I try to make a
choice with Lionel that's gonna affect
people whether it affects them in a
positive light or a negative light as I
say this is art it's all subjective you
know but I try to affect them in some in
some form of fashion and if I but if I
do have an effect on people then I'm
doing my job
no of course you always want to hear
their accolades of what a great
performance you gave and what you know
better I'd say it's it's it's it's art
and it and you know you're gonna have
you know 80% of the people gonna like it
there's always taking that 20% in ago
you know I wish he would've did it this
way or I wish you know while was this
way or you know so I try to I try to
find a keeps the truth in pin any of the
characters that ever play and also to
not judge I think we did way to me when
I judge the characters a recipe for
disaster but I mean Lionel was a
character that and that's that's how I
perceive him to be a guy who just kind
of fell in with the wrong crowd you know
a guy who just you know wants to be
accepted and in a felon see with stills
and all these other officers who were a
little jaded you had a you know had a
little bit of a jaded past and
and you know he just didn't want to be
the odd man out
so when Reese played by Jim Caviezel
turns the tables Lionel's taking Jim
Caviezel character ought to always
debate ooh to do away with them and when
when recent tables on he says lie loss
he'd be good at you but is I'm gonna
give you an opportunity because I see
the good in you but if you ever hurt
anyone again I'll be the first one to
kill you and that's pretty much how the
journey began with Milan these and this
is this is a pretty heavy question and
maybe I'm reading too much into this but
do you think that character because he's
redeemable gives other people hope that
maybe if they've made mistakes in years
prior that many people will judge them
for that they can move on from that or
is that maybe I'm getting too heady here
I know we all make mistakes and that's
what I got erases on pencils you know do
you know what I mean everyone makes a
mistake you know in and it's not about
where you've been it's about we are
going okay and that's the way I've
always kind of conducted my life I mean
there are things in my life I wish I
could you know did I did different you
know I really ideally be interested to
meet a man a woman who doesn't have you
know something in their life that they
that they wish they had made a different
choice you know what you know it is what
it is you know oh yeah I think I think I
think everyone has a redeemable quality
you know that's pretty much how I play
vital I playing with it you know as a
guy that you know he's his moral compass
was a little off and it needed to be
calibrated you know whether or not he's
a good cop doing bad things or a bad
cops doing good things
that's up to the viewer sir we love it
we've been speaking with actor Kevin
Chapman for more on Kevin please check
out his Facebook IMDB twitter @ p oh i
fusco and his amazing personal website
Kevin Chapman calm and also thanks to
the incredible
Wendy shepherd for arranging this
interview check out her sites at Studio
matrix calm and Wendy Shepard calm
Kevin we just want to thank you you know
with you know it's yeah this has been a
very really rich conversation it's been
great hearing about your backstory your
background and and also just how
grounded you are ok forward yeah
straightforward and direct and and just
you know I can see why so many
filmmakers you know so many people have
wanted to put you in their projects you
know because you're you just want to
roll up the sleeves and put in the work
and those are the kind of people you
want to kind of surround yourself with
so we thank you for for sharing that
with us today here on film courage sure
economy thank you very much you know
it's been a pleasure to be on the show I
can see why the audience likes him too
yeah yeah we can relate to that
yeah brings it to the screen yeah we
know you got a train to catch thank you
yes thank you
we'd also like to thank you very much
you got you we'd also like to thank our
guy Ronan Rosner he's the guy you seldom
see or hear but he plays a huge part in
what we do here and we thank you
and would you like to hear your project
or business mentioned during one of our
shows or displayed on our site to
advertise with film courage calm and our
radio program please inquire through
film courage comm via our contact page
would you like to hear more film courage
broadcast well you know they're
available on film cars.com
la talk radio comm and iTunes so please
make sure you subscribe we'll be back
here next Sunday on la talk radio calm
we're gonna have filmmakers Steve James
and Alex Kotlowitz yeah Steve and Alex
recently won an Independent Spirit Award
for their documentary the interrupter
'he's about the fascinating stories of
three violence interrupters who attempt
to protect their chicago communities
from the violence they were once a part
of and you may also know Steve James
from one of our favorite films the 94
documentary hoop dreams and Alex from
the best-selling book there are no
children here the story of two boys
growing up in the in the other America
for more on Steve James and Alex
Kotlowitz please visit interrupters dot
card Tim Quinn com
and that does it for us folks until next
Sunday have a great week
you